levandana has come back to his
neighborhood in karaman marash to
recover his belongings his family had to
move to a village nearby but Levante
says he intends to return as soon as his
parents house is rebuilt
I want to spend my life in Mirage I was
born here all I want is a home that is
built on Solid Ground and in line with
construction regulations
eager to counter growing criticism they
acted slowly during the earthquakes
government officials have pledged to
finish reconstruction within a year
this is the biggest earthquake
mobilization in the history of turkey
we're establishing new urban planning
for affected cities and we will ensure
the cultural and demographic identities
of those cities are preserved
earthquake debris is being cleared
Paving the way for huge construction
sites in affected areas City officials
say they are determined to build houses
that are going to be stronger safer and
better
Turkish Society is divided on how best
to move forward after the devastating
earthquakes and staggering death toll
the government insists on rebuilding
quickly so that those who lost their
homes can find a permanent shelter but
for many experts and Architects it's
about making sure cities and buildings
are designed to withstand powerful
earthquakes and save lives
but not everybody is convinced the
government is doing the right thing
is a construction engineer
he says the authorities should first
stop giving zoning amnestys to builders
who violate seismic construction codes
with the ongoing aftershocks from time
to time I'm wondering whether rebuilding
now is the right thing to do
the authorities have arrested dozens of
Builders and the mayor for violating
safety standards
for now victims of the earthquakes
continue to deal with grief they know
nothing will ever be able to compensate
for the loss of their loved onesh